you know I've heard you say that you
swear a lot and that got me thinking do
you prefer English swears or British
swears or you mean American I mean it
that's one yeah British sorry yeah
but no I don't I don't want to offend
any of you but British swearing is so
much better
British swearing is better because also
you can say stuffing you can get away
with it like what you can't get away
with the [ __ ] part here thing is a
decoy so I've heard bollocks that's a
swear in well your bollocks
well you seen you safe if something's
bollocks if you can say something is the
dog's bollocks and that means it's good
but if you say something is bollocks
that means it's bad but it's actually
generally referring to men's gonads yes
yes no but why would the dog's bollocks
be good that's the part that confuses me
because perhaps the dog managed to hang
on to them yeah maybe that's what it is
right that makes bollocks yeah that
means good do you swear in front of your
your boy unfortunately I do but he's he
charges me money
what do you mean he charges me $1 for a
swear and $2.00 for the f-word but he
does think the c-word is crap which is
great who thinks the c-word is crap yes
that's fantastic he doesn't know what
that there's another word that's a and I
frankly want to keep it that way however
I try really hard not to swear but he's
really really I owe him like five I
meant in like five hundred bucks you
know what's amazing is that my boy he
came to me one day this is years ago and
he just said I know what the F word is
and I went oh really and he's like yep I
heard at school and then he said and I
said well you can tell me just this one
time anyway yeah funk he thought it was
funk and there so we were we wanted him
to think that was the F word so we were
all like yeah that's the that's the F
word you know just be careful with that
and then the Bruno Mars song came out
where he says like yeah uptown funk he
was like how was it
this man screwed me we got away with it
you